chaos and confusion in some European
airports as travelers scramble for the
last flights to the United States from
Friday night all flights from 26
European countries will be banned for 30
days unprecedented action in
unprecedented times but welcomed by some
we are lucky to be able to leave Europe
if we are finally able to leave but the
EU was quick to condemn president
Trump's decision the European Union
disapproves of the fact that the u.s.
decision to impose a travel ban was
taken unilaterally and without
consultation but isolation both within
and from other countries is gaining
momentum as infection rates jump Italy
one of the worst affected nations
strengthened its nationwide quarantine
while Spain suspended Parliament and
football matches as death rates in the
country almost doubled in 24 hours
Frances president addressed the nation
directly spelling out some difficult
truths news on deku spite of our efforts
to delay it the virus continues to
propagate and it's accelerating we knew
it and feared it this evening I'm asking
all people who are more than 70 years of
age and those who suffer from chronic
illnesses or suffer from respiratory
problems people who were disabled to
remain as much as possible at home
though children only seem to suffer mild
symptoms they are considered key
spreaders of the virus and in response
Srilanka Ireland Denmark Norway and
France joined the long list of countries
to shut down all schools but the British
government continues to take a different
approach holding off on any wide-ranging
restrictions that would suppress the
spread now hoping instead to delay the
peak of the outbreak until the summer
all stages we have been guided by the
science and we will do the right thing
at the right time
we are not repeat not closing schools
now
the scientific advice is that this could
do more harm than good
meanwhile in China life at the epicenter
of the outbreak is gradually returning
to normal in Wuhan more than a thousand
patients waved goodbye to their hospital
beds and only a few dozen new cases were
recorded nationwide in South Korea the
number of new coronavirus cases is also
decreasing but the government warned
against premature optimism while in Iran
a thousand new infections the country
struggling with a lack of life-saving
equipment has asked for an emergency
five billion dollar loan from the
International Monetary Fund taking
fright at these world developments the
stock markets showed a sea of red with
the US Dow Jones entering a bear market
for the first time in 11 years not
helped by the announcement from the
European Central Bank then it will not
cut rates any further as the cracks
begin to show in economies and health
care systems across the world it is the
very human toll of kovat 19 that must be
remembered Charlie Angela al-jazeera